highlight of the news in 1936 is the application
of Edward da King of England monarch of the
British Empire Edward shown here reviewing
his troops culminates a storybook romance
with announcement of his intention of giving
up the throne to Wed Wallis Warfield Simpson
american-born socialite George v King of
England died January 20th 1936 with Britain
mourning its loss and hailing its new ruler
the king is dead long live the king Edward
the aid forsaking his Prince of Wales title
for the mantle of a monarch assumed official
duties as head of the military but peace
was in his heart all through his reign
in one of his early appearances before his
people he declared humanity tries out the
peace and the assurance of faith a speech
for which he received an ovation from his
subjects final act before the application
was a visit by the ruler to the people of
Wales where reports of poor conditions in
the mines had been brought to his attention
and then Britain hears rumors of the abdication
crowds wait for an announcement from the Prime
Minister making no secret of their sentiments
where their king is concerned Stanley Baldwin
Britain's Prime Minister leaves number 10 Downing
Street with official word of the application
the Duke of York shown here with his wife Princess
Elizabeth and sister Margaret roles is to be the
new English ruler and the first application in
the history of Britain is to be accepted with
mingled emotions by England's people but there
will be nothing uncertain about their loyalty
to George the sixth and Elizabeth soon to be
king and queen of the British Empire meanwhile
all Britain waits for the official explanation
of the abdication from Windsor Castle and on
December 11th 1936 Edward prepares to make it
radio links lands as the world tunes in and the
moment for Edwards talk is here at long low I am
able to say a human of my own this was nothing I
had to judge entirely for myself during these
four days I had been comforted by her matter
my mother and by her by my family it may be some
time before I return to my native land and now
we all have the new king I wish him and you his
people happiness and prosperity but oh my god